ten-year-old matthew kirkpatrick spent
the summer gaining independence but
about of covid19 at the start of the
school year has stripped it all away the
doctors were saying
nothing alone no showering alone you
know if he was trying to learn to cook
no cooking alone um
you know no
no physical activities nancy kirkpatrick
says the life-limiting advice came after
her son collapsed on his way home from
school there's this alleyway near my
house and
i passed out and
then i just woke up he had two more
severe blackouts
one was at school where he just fell out
of his desk matthew's post-coveted
symptoms also included chest pain and
dizziness a cardiologist diagnosed him
with tachycardia a condition where the
heartbeat races more than 100 times per
minute a new large-scale pre-print study
looked at more than 80 thousand children
with covid while cardiorespiratory
post-covet symptoms were more rare it
found one in four kids who had the virus
developed some form of lancovid the most
common symptoms that were seen were mood
symptoms sleep disturbances and fatigue
and these can be sort of um really
common symptoms after anybody recovers
from a viral illness but
it is concerning that we saw those
symptoms continue for at least a month
after somebody had covered claire
hastie's 13 year old twins got coveted
two years ago they've been dealing with
lingering fatigue gastrointestinal
issues and extreme joint pain ever since
it's heartbreaking all of the relapses
and symptoms have really made it
difficult there are a few answers
treatment can be limited and prevention
vaccination isn't available to everyone
matthew kirkpatrick wasn't eligible for
a vaccine when he caught covet in
september you know i regret to this day
putting him in school until he was
vaccinated
a risk some families are still being
forced to take as they wait for an
approved vaccine for the youngest
canadians jamie morocco global news
toronto